vous bienvenue aux jsp aux jeunes
sapeurs pompiers dans leur nord
le samedi c'est la formation incendie
mais ce mercredi ils sont une trentaine
à la caserne de fleury les aubrais pour
une séance sport hockey en suspens toi
la corde gauche droite l'échelle
accroché où on tait force des bras force
du dos tout le temps ok si les épreuves
du parcours sportif en fait il ya deux
les cordes ya du lancer de poids
toutes ces activités en lien avec l'ars
avec les pompiers regarde toujours en
rien jamais en bas les pompiers 10
loiret compte douze sections jeunes des
structures entre clubs de sport
formation et vie collective
ça me permet de sa rentrée des jeunes à
partir de 12 ans en tant que jeunes
sapeurs pompiers pour leur faire
apprendre le savoir être et le savoir
faire donc aussi bien le tout ce qui est
politesse le respect de l'horaire le
respect de la hiérarchie et après ils
ont quatre ans pour apprendre le métier
de sapeur pompier si le sport est
intensif et la discipline rigoureuse
les jeunes sapeurs-pompiers apprécié cet
esprit de caserne va séduire mais en
même temps c'est un peu le but de france
il faut il faut que ça soit dur pour que
pour progresser et avancer
je savais que ça allait être très
sportif et rigoureux dans ce qu'on
allait faire donc je m'attendais à ça
mais très confiant à mesure ça devient
plus difficile mais vu qu'on que non on
évolue bas c'est mieux j'aime bien que
soient strictes carré et tout est bien
tout et tout est plié tout est carré ici
à fleury c'est un pompier volontaire qui
préside la section jeunes en encadrant
ces enfants il applique la recette qui
lui a si bien réussi dans sa propre vie
enfin les jsp sur la sam a servi dans de
grands travaux complémentaires et
d'acquérir un savoir être que que j'ai
dans la vie de tous les jours ce soit
devenu professionnel ou au sein de la
caserne est aujourd'hui le fait de
l'heure
de leur inculquer ces valeurs là
et pour moi indispensable pour leur
réussite plus tard est ce que vous savez
approximativement combien de temps vous
la montée la corde formation sport
esprit collectif
les jsp sont aussi une école de la
citoyenneté qui reprend la maxime des
pompiers courage et dévouement